hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to
interpret the systolic and diastolic
sounds when taking a manual blood
pressure first gather your supplies and
perform hand hygiene position the
patient properly ensuring their back is
supported their arm is at heart level
and their feet are uncrossed if
necessary support the arm and make sure
their palms are facing up then find the
brachial artery near the top of the
elbows bin place an appropriately sized
cup on the patient's bare skin and
secure it in place the cuff's base
should be about two inches above the
elbow bend and the cuff's arrow should
be in line with the brachial artery's
palpation point attach the gauge to the
cuff making sure it is easy to view then
tighten the valve on the bowl by turning
it in a clockwise direction remember the
phrase righty tighty lefty loosey and
make sure the gauge reads zero next
estimate the systolic pressure number
first by palpating the patient's
brachial artery as you pump the bulb the
point at which you no longer feel the
brachial artery is the estimated
systolic pressure that you need to
remember our patience is 116. then
deflate the cuff by turning the bulb's
valve counterclockwise and wait 60
seconds next put on the stethoscope
palpate again to find the brachial
artery and place the stethoscope's bell
or diaphragm over the brachial artery
without occluding it confirm the gauge
is at zero tighten the bulb's valve by
turning it clockwise and pump the bulb
until the gauge reads 30 millimeters of
mercury higher than the estimated
systolic number that you noted earlier
so based on our patient's estimated
systolic pressure we're going to inflate
to 146 millimeters of mercury then
slowly turn the valve counterclockwise
until the needle begins to drop at a
speed of two millimeters of mercury per
second listen closely for the first
sound to appear and note the reading on
the gauge this is the systolic blood
pressure which is the top number you
need to remember continue to allow air
to leave the cuff and note the point on
the gauge when the sound stops
completely this is the diastolic
pressure number which is the bottom
number you need to remember and i do
just want to point out that in the past
the last sound heard was a diastolic
number but now many guidelines consider
the diastolic to be the point at which
the sound stops
now let's listen for the systolic and
diastolic numbers together to help you
understand how to determine the
patient's blood pressure
[Music]
in this example our patient's blood
pressure is 110 over 70. fully open the
valve to deflate the cuff then remove
the cuff clean your supplies and perform
hand hygiene and then be sure to
document the blood pressure reading and
the arm that was used okay so that wraps
up this video on how to take a manual
blood pressure and if you'd like to
watch more nursing skill videos you can
access the link in the youtube
description below